health problems I'm turning 37 this week
and two years ago on my birthday was
sort of this this nadir of of health
problems and in fact I had so many
problems I had to write them down so
that I could remember how many health
problems I had
I've got Christopher Kelly with me and
dr. Tommy woods and we're gonna talk
they're both from a company called
nourish balance thrive and they've
helped me out immensely over the last
two years with with a lot of these
health problems I've had so Chris I
reached out to you it was literally on
my birthday when we talked about wow if
you know this but it was my 35th
birthday yeah and I'm just gonna paint
the picture for everyone I I've had a
mint back pain since I was a teen I
broke my my l5 and eventually fused to
my s1 in fact whenever I get laughs I
got an MRI or cat scan doctors like oh
you must have had a surgery to have that
fused and no they just sort of grew
together and and I couldn't sit down for
like six months when I was a freshman in
high school because of that in Ohio
where I grew up we were playing ice
basketball one day and someone tackled
me during ice basketball and ever since
then I've had some back issues and and
it really I was under control throughout
most of my 20s and then in my 30s it
started to get more and more pronounced
than the pain was really bad the
beginning of 2016 January 2016 I was
waking up with ten out of ten horrible
like sciatica and just the pain was
unbearable like so unbearable I was like
how am I gonna get through this next
second and so I started to see different
doctors and I I saw a surgeon and I was
two weeks out from having surgery and
then but but that I found out about this
type of physical therapy that I started
doing it's called a gas Q therapy and
I'm sure we can talk about that if
necessary but that helped out a little
bit with the back pain but I suspected
something else was wrong like maybe
there was some hormonal imbalance or or
something because I wasn't sort of
recovering the way that it that I
like I was doing two hours of physical
therapy every day but it wasn't really
taking like it should and on top of that
when I was about age 27 I started
developing these weird allergies like
seasonal allergies but also chemical
sensitivities - I moved into this
apartment and all of a sudden it was
right after my divorce and I I thought
maybe I'm just depressed but I didn't
really see the correlation right away I
would go into a I'd go home and I start
feeling these weird symptoms my throat
would get sore and my eyes would get
watery I started to have this really
weak pathetic call just and and I
thought oh maybe I'm depressed and I
went to a doctor and I said oh yeah well
you just your mom died your marriage and
you're probably depressed right now and
I went to another doctor he's like oh no
no no it's not depression it's asthma
here's an inhaler have a good day and I
saw several doctors I couldn't really
figure out and then I moved and those
symptoms got better all of a sudden I
moved into a place that I didn't have a
chemical sensitivity to and then I kind
of ignored the symptoms because they
weren't bad enough that I they weren't
causing enough pain that I was willing
to make some radical changes in my life
but then around age 34 and 35 it all
started to come crashing down I moved
into this apartment in Montana and I was
so allergic to it for lack of a better
word so sensitive it had just refinished
the floors they just painted the walls
and I felt like I couldn't breathe in
there I had to move out like emergency
level couldn't couldn't stand it anymore
and I started to feel helpless I started
to feel this type of despair there was
this sensitivity there but then I was
having all these gut problems at the
same time like I it was hard for me to
digest anything like wheat or just
carbohydrates in general like anytime I
would eat fiber I had the worst kind of
gas and it was it was terrible but then
around the summer of 2016 I started
getting like brain fog
and then I got this temporary memory
loss like short-term memories were just
gone and I couldn't and then I started
to not be able to remember basic words
like I would look at the table but I
wouldn't remember that it was called a
table like what's the name was Brian
hanging this thing it was so frightening
and and and then like my hormones were
all out of whack like I'm in the best
relationship I've ever been in Rebecca
my partner is amazing she's so
supportive and we're gonna actually talk
a little bit about that today having
supportive people when we're going
through these health problems in fact
she's made it so much easier for me to
get through a lot of these health
problems but she's been so supportive
and I'm in this great relationship with
a person I'm so attracted to but my
libido was through the floor summer of
2016 not only was my libido through
before but I I had problems with
erectile dysfunction and so I'm like
okay wait a minute I've got terrible
back pain horrible back pain I've got
brain fog I can't remember stuff I can't
digest things I can't be around paint or
any sort of chemicals without having all
these terrible allergies I had horrible
seasonal allergies and it got to a point
and probably my hormones are so out of
whack that I'm not even attracted the
person I'm attracted to I'm not
attracted anyone I have no desire to
have sex or anything like what the hell
is going on with me and then I got
desperate and so where do you go and you
get desperate Google and I I stumbled
across this this website for this
company called nourish balance thrive it
was actually you did a podcast of the
guy named Ben Greenfield oh yeah I
didn't this I had no idea but Ben
Greenfield was already I had no idea who
you were but thanks to Google it
connected me to the Ben Greenfield
podcast and then you were talking about
many of the things that were going on
with me and I realized like wow maybe
maybe there's some sort of solution now
obviously I wanted a magic pill I wanted
a I wanted to call Chris up and say hey
give me a prescription to fix this
immediately
and I remember talking to you on my 35th
birthday and the thing that you said to
me he said hey it's gonna be okay and
III can't tell you like how relieving
that was I know it was like the
strangest sort of like it's weird that I
needed permission for to realize like oh
maybe this is going to be okay because
to be honest with you that summer I
really thought I was dying
well I thought this was the slow descent
towards death I mean when you start
losing your memory hmm all of a sudden
you're like oh I mean I got my will and
order and I I'm I was preparing to like
oh this this might be the end of it all
and I talked to you on the phone and you
said hey oh yeah we've got a program I
could try to work with you we can do
some testing and we could talk about
some of these problems and you started
talking to me about really basic things
like sleep and hormones and diet and
exercise and and these are all things
that I knew like fundamentally but like
we started getting into the more
granular things that would be more
applicable for me like we all know the
diet and exercise and sleep are
important and I had a pretty good diet
and exercise regimen and and I had what
I thought was a decent sleep regimen
that actually wasn't but it is now
thankfully and over the last two years
we have slowly worked together to try to
get to the bottom of what these health
problems are
you